Vladimir Putin begins his fourth term as
Russian president this morning Putin was
sworn in during a ceremony marking his
18th year in power
protesters opposed to his lengthy rural
clash with police over the weekend
officers arrested more than 1500 people
Elizabeth Palmer is in Moscow with the
issues Putin faces this term Elizabeth
good morning good morning well this year
the Kremlin had announced that the
inauguration was going to be low-key but
from what we saw there was still plenty
of pomp and ceremony
this is the fourth time Vladimir Putin
has taken the presidential oath of
office fittingly enough he addressed the
nation from what was a hundred years ago
the throne room of the tars in the
Kremlin palace his message emphasized
tradition and family values as well as
strength as head of state he said I will
do everything to multiply Russia's power
the ceremony was elaborately
choreographed with military salutes and
a meet-and-greet to highlight his
popularity with young people not all
young people though on Saturday there
were demonstrations across the country
called by the opposition leader Alexei
Navalny against what he calls the rigged
elections that gave Putin another term
down with Qatar the crowd chanted before
police moved in arrested Navalny and
then dispersed his supporters there were
similar clashes across the country the
Kremlin's way of harassing any kind of
anti Putin protests and although more
than a thousand people were arrested
none of it was carried on the main
Russian TV news now the analysts that
we've been talking to in Moscow say that
a new term doesn't mean a new Putin
we're going to be seeing more of the
same that is an authoritarian government
at home with plenty of corruption and
abroad an aggressive Putin who will
continue to attack Western democracies
with disinformation and cyber weapons
Elizabeth Palmer in Moscow thanks
Elizabeth